et maintenant dans le cadre des amitiés
hispano sudamericano mexicano cubaine
voici mars élite aux amandes t.cam
patron c'est moi
mais voyez canada plc you want claudio
pasqualin attention une occasion
française
les silverbacks de la musique car les
amours et les valeurs une occasion qui
sans doute il se dit qu'ils soient
conscients que la petite vieille
l'appui nécessaire de tomber bien pour
les mamies
nouvel élan qui chassait le ciel lourd
et noah chi que l'idée ne fait rien
contre un autre amour il nous fait la
nuit yakou vrai complément que la
rencontre et moi ici là la cité peppers
de l'entrée même la réponse pour aller
bien
selon la cimade qui toi et moi collée
dans les bars et les citoyens comment la
peau et pour fanny l'abandon et civils
des fermiers vin bien bien bien bien
bien bien dans cette grange étendons
sous les murs l'intestin
non lisez le destin a décidé si transe
quand ils s'éclairent déchiré la
fauverie sont pas tous mais déjà nous
naissons attendons des paires sont ils
au tiers mouche dit de rester là na na
na na na
à
le primat me viennent tempérer moi
c'était béchir était pâle était
d'emmener les l'école bon et on s'est
dit ça c'est les dons qu'elle est jolie
lily les boulots profitons nettoiement
qui tourne à la masia
les parties